les lots me lahlali france
là où elle est
agile comme des chats il à peynier et
déloger l'ennemi malgré ses
retranchements
ah les combats avec les allemands ont
été très dur même si ça n'a duré que
trois jours on s'est accroché avec eux
et nous sommes sortis nous tranché et
nous avons tiré de boue nous avons sauté
sur nos ennemis pour les attraper tout
simplement
eh oui
boursica com
rien n'aurait été possible s'il n'y
avait pas eu l'apport irremplaçable des
6600 soldats marocains ils étaient venus
combattre
loin de leur terre loin de leur famille
ils sont tombés dans nos montagnes et
sur nos plaines mais je la sueur
aujourd'hui ils ne tomberont jamais dans
l'oubli